içimizde öğrenci arkadaşlarımız var
mezun olacaklar ve İnşallah ileride
üniversite hayatına başlayacaklar
üniversite hayatı bittikten sonra da iş
görüşmelerin ve Hani o iş mülakatlarında
bilindik bir soru vardır ya
kendinizi 5 yıl sonra nerede
görüyorsunuz Bu Klişe bir soru ama belli
bir amacı var tabii ki birincisi sizin
beş yıl sonrası için bir planınız var mı
Bunu öğrenmek istiyorlar ikincisi varsa
bu planınız ne Bunu öğrenmek istiyorlar
ve üçüncüsü bu planınız şirket
politikalarıyla uyuşuyor mu yani bir
karakter testi yani aslına bakarsanız
sizin 5 yıl sonra kahramanı olacağınız
hikayenin senaryosunu istiyorlar Peki
günümüz şartlarında Tüketimin bu kadar
yoğunlaştığı Her şeyi çok çabuk
tükettiğimiz ve sadece giyim yeme içme
değil popüler kültürde çok çabuk
tükettiğimiz Şu dönemde bırakın 5 yılı 5
ay sonrası için plan yapabilmek bu kadar
kolay mı
Düşünsenize pandemi döneminde hepimiz
evlerde kapalı kaldık ve Akrabalarımız
da arkadaşlarımızla iletişimimiz kesildi
O dönem bir aplikasyon çıktı hatırlıyor
musunuz böyle bir İnsanlar bir odada
sohbet ediyordu Online olarak hatırlayan
var mı o aplikasyonu
bakın Akasya Hanım hatırladı sadece Club
House Halbuki o İlk çıktığında ne kadar
popülerdi değil mi Ama Bakın şu anda hiç
kimse Hatırlamıyor bu kadar hızlı
değişen bir ortamda gerçekten 5 yıl
sonrasının planını yapmak çok da
mantıklı değil Çok doğru da değil Zira
bugünün popüler bir konusuna Ben bu
konuda kendimi yatırım yapayım Dediğiniz
zaman siz daha kendinizi geliştirene
kadar o artık popüler olmayabiliyor Peki
bu durumda ne yapmak lazım bu durumda
Belki de bize düşen Aslında kendimizi
keşfetmek kendi yeteneklerimizi ve neyi
yapmaktan keyif alıyoruz Neyi yaparken
yorulmuyoruz onu bir iş gibi görmüyoruz
bunu keşfetmek ve yaptığımız işi bir
tutkuya dönüştürmek Ben Erciyes
Üniversitesi mezunuyum
2000'li yılların başında üniversiteye
ilk girdiğimiz dönem
o zamanlar internet Bu kadar yaygın
değil sosyal medya yok ve iletişim
kanalları bu kadar yoğun değil
Dolayısıyla bizim sektörden bilinen
insanlarla ünlü insanlarla bir araya
gelmemizin yegane yolu bugün burada
olduğu gibi Aslında okulumuzda
gerçekleşen bir takım etkinliklerdi o
etkinliklerden birinde esragonun o zaman
Microsoft Türkiye'nin İnsan Kaynakları
müjdesi çiçeği burnunda genç bir
hanımefendi bizim kariyer etkinliğimize
gelmişti güzel bir konuşma oldu ve bu
konuşmanın sonrasında soru cevap kısmına
geçildi tahmin edeceğiniz üzere sorulan
soru Microsoft Türkiye'de işe alım
yaparken hangi kriterlere dikkat
ediyorsunuz bizim Türklerde şöyle bir
özellik var Birinde bir soru
sorulduğunda onun ne cevap vereceğini
tahmin etme gibi bir özelliğiniz var
böyle hemen yorum yaparız Ben de öyle
yaptım ve dedim ki vereceği cevap belli
sonuç itibariyle Microsoft dünyanın en
büyük yazılım firması ve Buraya tabii ki
Sıradan insanlar almayacaklar şimdi
diyecek ki işte Türkiye'nin şu şu
üniversitelerinden mezun olması veya
yurt dışında Master doktora yapmış
olması ya da İngilizce Tamam da ikinci
bir yabancı dil olması gibi şeyler
söyleyecek diye beklerken Esra Hanım
öyle bir şey söyledi ki
Biz işine tutkuyla yapan insanlarla
çalışmak isteriz ve bütün ölçülme
değerlendirmelerimizi bu kriteri ölçmek
için kullanırız Tabii çok genciz o
zamanlar üniversite çağları ve bunu
algılamakta biraz zorlandım Bir de şu da
var hani bu Amerikalı firmaların havalı
kelimeleri kullanma özelliği var acaba
öyle bir şey mi diye düşünürken Aslında
Zaman geçtikçe bunun ne kadar da doğru
bir yaklaşım olduğunu gördüm ve işini
tutkuyla yapan insanların hayatta ne
kadar başarılı olduklarını birer işaret
oldu bir fotoğraf göstereceğim bu
fotoğraftaki Kişiyi tanıyan var mı
Ben söyleyeyim Eren Ali
bakmayın böyle havalı durduğuna Eren
Aslında dedik ya az o da bizden biri
Malatyalı Bir Köy Çocuğu Aslında
İlkokulu annesinin 5 farklı sınıfta
eğitim verdiği bir köy okulunda bitirdi
Daha sonra Malatya Fen Lisesi'ni kazandı
Ve burada matematik olimpiyatlarında
derece aldı bu dereceden sonra emanete
gibi büyük üniversitelerden kabul
almasına rağmen cesaret edemeyip ODTÜ
Bilgisayar Mühendisliği bölümüne
başvurdu okulu bitirdikten sonra
girişimci de bir tarafı var ve
aklında bir proje var öğrenci ile
eğitmeni bir araya getirecek bir
platform kurmaya çalıştı bununla alakalı
birçok yatırımcıyla görüştü fakat Fikri
değer görmedim bunun üzerine direksiyonu
silikon vadisine kırdı ve yaklaşık 2
yılda orada yatırımcı aradı ve 2 yılın
sonunda yaklaşık 57 yatırımcıyla
görüştükten sonra 58 yatırımcı fikrini
verdi ve şirketini kurdu Aslında şöyle
dersem sanırım herkes bilecek
dünyanın şu anda en büyük online Eğitim
Platformu ve 50 milyondan fazla
öğrencisi 150 binden fazla öğretmeni
olan ama okulu olmayan bir eğitim
platformunu kurucusu Eren Bali işte Esra
Hanım'ın söylediği o Tutku meselesi
burada karşımıza çıkıyor Eren'in bir
akrabası yoktu Eren'in parası yoktu
Eren'in torpil yapacak kimsesi yoktu ki
bunu görüyoruz yatırımına kimse değer
vermedi ama o inandığı şeyin arkasında
tutkuyla devam etti ve bugün dünyanın en
büyük online eğitim platformunu kurdu ve
Bugün Türkiye'de yaklaşık bir buçuk
milyondan fazla insan sadece Türkiye'de
bu platformda yararlanıyor hayatta canlı
ya da yanıtsız küçük ya da büyük her
şeyin arasında bir bağlantı var Bunu ben
söylemiyorum bunu bilim söylüyor aslında
ve son dönemde bununla alakalı ciddi
çalışmalar yapılıyor Hayatın kendisi
aslında bir örüntüye sahip ve biz bu
örüntüyü çözmeye çalışıyoruz ve bunun
ismine de yeni bir yaklaşım var
bağlantısal bütünselliğin matematiği
deniliyor yeni bir matematik yaklaşımı
Hatta bu konuda Bahçeşehir Üniversitesi
Tıp Fakültesi dekanı Türker Kılıç
hocamız Var YouTube'da videolarını
bulabilirsiniz Bir de kitabı var
bakmanızı tavsiye ederim Gerçekten bunun
üzerine çalışan bir beyin cerrahı ve bir
beyin cerrahından yapay zekayı dinlemek
gerçekten çok keyifli bir yerlerde denk
gelirse mutlaka dinlemenizi tavsiye
ederim dedik ya her şeyin arasında bir
bağlantı var bir Metafor var ya hani
Kelebek Etkisi Afrika'da Kanatçı falan
bir kelebek Amerika'da bir fırtınaya
sebep olabilir Nasıl ya Yani bir kelebek
bırakın bir fırtına yelpazesi bile
yapmaz aslında yani burada kanadını
çıkarsa ben onun rüzgarını hissetmem ama
onunla bağlantılı başka küçük etkenler o
kadar birbirini etkileyerek devam ediyor
ki sonunda bir fırtınaya sebep
olabiliyor ve bizim hayatımızda Aslında
basitmiş gibi gördüğümüz gibi çok şey
aslında gelecek hayatımızın çok çok
önemli kırılma noktaları olarak
karşımıza çıkıyor da biz bunu ne zaman
fark ediyoruz ancak gelecek geldiği
zaman fark ediyor O yüzden doğru olan
nokta bizim tamamen kendimize yatırım
yapmamız ve kendimizi keşfetmemiz Bu
benim
sanıyorum bundan yaklaşık 23 yıl önceki
halim Gördüğünüz üzere daha genç ve daha
zayıf üniversiteye başladığım dönem
dediğim gibi Erciyes Üniversitesi
bilgisayar mühendisliği bölümüne
başladım ben ve çok bilinçsiz bir
seçimdi Yani bir bilgisayar mühendisinin
Ne iş yapacağını bilmeden hayatında da
hiç Bilgisayarım olmadan ve puanım Tıp
gibi başka bölümlere de yatarken Ailemde
o bölümlere gitmemiz isterken her ne
hikmetse insiyatif alıp Bilgisayar
Mühendisliği bölümüne girdim fakat
bölüme sonra Şunu fark ettim bu böyle
bir hevesle olacak bir şey değil yani
bilgisayarla alakalı bir bağlantınızın
olması gerekiyor ki bir şeyler
yapabilirsiniz içimizde yazılımla
uğraşan arkadaşlar vardır Hoca tahtada
şey anlatıyor algoritmalar dersini
anlatıyor ve yazılımda şey vardır iyi
eşittir iyi artı bir diye bir şey var
aslında bir değeri bir arttırmaktır o ve
iyi eşittir i+1 diye yazıyor Ben ÖYS
matematiğiyle gelmişim bir denklemde bir
değişken nasıl kendisinin bir fazlasına
eşit olabilir kafamda daha bu en basit
kurguyu bile yapamazken yanındaki
arkadaşım teknik liseden gelmiş Yılan
oyunu yazıyor
ve ben kontrolcüye kontrol ve bilmediğim
için bütün kitaptaki kodları
üşenmeden tekrar yazdığımı hatırlıyorum
tabi böyle olunca müthiş bir hayal
kırıklığı ve Birinci sınıfın sonunda
işte zayıflar var müthiş bir moralsizlik
var ve kendi kendime yanlış bölümü
seçtim Yol yakınken buradan dönmeliyim
düşüncesi aslında
kafamda bu düşüncelerle devam ederken o
zaman bir yarışma düzenleniyordu
Microsoft'un düzenlediği bir yarışma ilk
defa bu sene düzenlendi üniversiteler
arası bilgisayar mühendislikleri
arasında proje yarışması arkadaşlarım bu
yarışmaya katılıyorlardı ve onlardan bir
davet geldi Ömer sen de Bizim ekibe
katıl dedim ki Ben yazılırım
beceremiyorum Yapamıyorum sevmiyorum
Beni niye ekibe dahil ediyorsunuz ya
işte adam eksiğimiz var sen de gel Peki
girdim gönüllü gönülsüz
sonra işin içine girince
bazen gerçeğin kendisi nasıl gördüğünüle
alakalı Benim verdiğim karar yazılımı
sevmiyorum yazılımı beceremiyorum 3
aylık proje zamanı içerisinde Şunu fark
ettim Ben yazılımı hem becerebiliyorum
hem seviyorum sonra ne oldu biliyor
musunuz 96 tane proje Türkiye'deki bütün
bilgisayar mühendisliklerinden bunlar
için ne kadar bildiğin uzunsa varsa 96
proje içerisinde Biz Türkiye üçüncüsü
olduk Bu benim hayatımı çok çok önemli
bir kırılma noktasıdır Zira bir özgüven
kazandım 2 kendimi keşfettim Ömer tam da
yapmak istediğin mesleği şu anda
yapıyorsun diye
Tabii bu özgüvenle
Microsoft'un yine bir programı daha var
Yazın Staj var Yaz okulu stajı var
Türkiye'deki bütün Bilgisayar
Mühendisliği öğrencilerinden birer
kişiyi alıp Eğitim Bir ay boyunca
ücretsiz eğitim veriyorlar ona başvurdum
benimle beraber birçok arkadaşımla
başvurdu ama ben kabul aldım neden bu
yarışmada elde ettiğim derece yüzünden
ve Bunun sayesinde çok iyi bir eğitim
aldım okul bitecek artık kapanacak iş
başvuruları var kayseri'deyiz o zaman
Kayseri'nin en büyük şiddeti İstikbal
Mobilya oraya başvurmak istedim
herkes Oraya girmek istiyor
ve belli şartları var işte askerlik
yapmayanı kesinlikle almıyorlar benim
özgeçmişi baktılar işte yarışmada derece
Ondan sonra işte Microsoft Yaz okulunda
eğitim alma benim için bu kuralı
estettiler ve ben orada işe başladım
Burada 8 yıl boyunca çalıştım buranın
bana katkısı çok fazla oldu çünkü Yapı
çok büyük Şirket çok büyük büyüklükten
kastım Bu arada kurumsallık ya
30 saniyede bir kanepeye şükret ve
oradaki veri sırası yeni yönetecek bir
akla bir ihtiyaç var ve ister istemez O
iş size bunu çok güzel şekilde öğretiyor
ve burada edindiğim deneyimlerle 8
buçukta burada çalıştım ve sonrasında
şimdiki çalıştığım iş yeri olan ıslandı
bunun ayeti yöneticisi olarak göreve
başladım
kapı kapıyı açtı
sonra tabii Bizim formatımızdaki
insanlar rutini çok sevmiyor belli bir
şekilde hayatın içine bindiği anda
farklı araçlara giriyorsunuz bir gün bir
arkadaşım üniversiteden bir arkadaşım
dedi ki bana Ömer Ya sen bizim
bilgisayar mühendisliği bölümünde
derslere girmek ister misin dışarıdan
misafir öğretim görevlisi olarak daha
önce hiç denediğim bir şey değil peki
dedim
ve üniversitede derslere girmeye
başladım haftada 4 var son sınıflara
burada kendime bir misyon gittim Dedim
ki Ömer sen özel sektörden geliyorsun
özel sektörün Bu çocuklardan ne
istediğini biliyorsun pratik bilgi
akademinin Bu çocuklara ne veremediğini
biliyorsun teorik bilgi O zaman sen
burada bir aracı ol ve bu çocukları
sektörü Elinden geldiği kadar
hazırlamaya çalışır kendimce kurallar
koydum derste tahta kullanmak yok slayt
kullanmak yok Bunu tutmak yok full
uygulamalı dersler olacak Burada işte
gerçekten bir
üzerinde bir işlem gerçekleştireceksek o
videoyu orada sinirlenip performans
testlerini yapalım bir robot uygulaması
yapacaksak uzaktan kontrollü onu orada
Dizayn edelim yazılımını orada yapalım
gibi böyle pratik bilgilerle dolu bir
eğitim döneme geçirdi Ama tabi bu
anlatırken güzel de
bunu benim yapmam değil o çocukların
yapması önemli iki saatlik bir derste
100 kişiyle bunu yapmanın imkanı yok o
zaman dedim ki ben ödev vereyim Bu
çocuklara ve vize de finalde bu ödevler
geçerli olsun bu sefer çocuklardan şöyle
bir şey geldi hocam siz anlatıyorsunuz
ama bununla alakalı Biz not tutamıyoruz
ne yapabiliriz peki dedim Bundan sonra
derslerimizi kayıt altına alalım ve
YouTube'da bir kanal açıp oraya atalım
ve Ders kayıtlarını oraya atmaya
başladık Tabi YouTube kapalı bir mecra
değil herkese açık bir Mezra olduğu için
benim öğrencilerden farklı farklı
insanlardan da mesaj atanlar abone
olanlar vesaireler geldi ve aslında
kendi çapında Ben bir YouTube kanalı
oluşturmuş oldum şimdi kendime daha
fazla dikkat etmeye başladım daha az
öksürüyorum daha iyi mikrofon
kullanıyorum vesaire derken ve bir gün
bir mesaj aldım Ömer Bey merhaba sizin
YouTube kanalınızı inceledik
eğitimlerinizi Beğendik Sizin için de
uygunsa bize eğitim hazırlar mısınız
diyen kim biliyor musunuz
bakıyorum 1 gün Hiç Kimse almadı ikinci
gün hiç kimse almadı 3 gün Hiç Kimse
almadı ve dedim ki Ömer Tamam buraya
kadar
Sen normal hayatına devam et dördüncü
gün bir kişi aldı 5 gün 2-3 derken ne
oldu biliyor musunuz 6 ay sonra benim
eğitimim kendi kategorisinin en çok
satan oldu ve an itibariyle şu anda
dünyanın 106 farklı ülkesinden 45 günden
fazla öğrenci var ve 6 tane kurs
yayınladım 2 tanesi kendi kategorisinden
çok satan oldu
bizim eğitmenler bölümüne girdiğimiz
yerde şöyle bir harita var Dünya
üzerinde eğitimlerinizi alan kişilerin
bulunduğu bir dünya haritası haritada
yerini bilmediğim ülkelerden
öğrencilerin olması çok güzel
nikaragua'dan işte kongo'dan
filipinler'den vesaire şu an mesela
meksika'dan 21 tane öğrencim varmış Bu
gerçekten çok enteresan ve Aslında
çağımızın ne kadar fırsatlarla dolu
olduğunu bize sunan bir görüntü
borsasına girdiler 2019 yılında ileminin
eğitmenler toplantısı vardı ona Gittik
Tabii herkes gitmedi çünkü paralı bir
etkinlik olduğu için yüreğinin bir süre
eğitmeni var ama oraya giden yaklaşık
200 Kişiydik Herkesin üzerinde böyle şey
var Kim olduğunu anlatan Ömer Çolakoğlu
from Turkey işte ne anlatıyorsa ayeti
hiç teknoloji kendilerini kocaman
anlatan bir şey var ki herkes birbirini
görsün de rahat iletişim kursun diye
Türkiye'den 3-4 kişi falan gitmiştik
dünyanın farklı farklı yerlerinden gelen
insanlar var ilk gün bizim kafe gibi bir
yerde topladılar dediler ki girin buraya
Network oluşturun insanlarla tanışın
Tamam bir iki sohbet ettik falan
sonra ben bir sıkıldım herhalde bir
kahve aldım bir kenara geldim Yanıma
biri geldi Bir de aradan gizeminin kendi
çalışanları var ve burasında staf
yazıyor personel gelene işte Hoş geldin
falan diyorlar biri geldi yanıma işte
Ömer nasılsın Yolculuğun nasıl geçti
Berlin'i sevdim mi falan böyle bir
sohbet etmeye başladı Ben onu isimliğine
baktım saf yazıyor Hadi dedim bak Beni
burada yalnız gördü sohbet etmek için
geldi sağ olsun 15 dakika falan konuştuk
şey yaptık neyse o gün bitti ertesi gün
otelde etkinlik başlıyor sonucu şey dedi
Şimdi dedi konuşmalarını yapmak üzere
ceo'muz direkt kokari'yi sahneye davet
ediyoruz bir gün önce burasına saf
yazdıran adam Üç buçuk milyar dolarlık
şirketin
Bu benim çok tuhafıma gitti ya
Türkiye'de böyle bir şey adamın yanına
ne koruma var ne asistan var ne başka
bir şey var ben onun arkasından
koşmuyorum O benim yanıma geliyor sohbet
ediyor ve burasına saf yazdıracak
herhalde mütevazi bir insan Gerçekten bu
çok etkilendiğim bir olay oldu
etkinliğin sonunda yanına gittim tebrik
ettim dedim ki direkt bu fotoğraf
çektirebilir miyiz tabii dedi Ondan
sonra elimde Makina çekecek adam yok
birini elletti dövmelerle bir
fotoğrafınızı çek Ondan sonra adam çekti
olmuş mu dedi yok olmamış mı dedim Tamam
dedi gitti Bir daha çekti falan o da
Vice present
gerçekten şunu gördüm Hani Gönüller
alçaldıkça insanların gönlünde nasıl
yükseldiğini gördü ve kendime çok örnek
aldığım bir davranış oldu işte Birileri
yapar birileri de böyle fotoğraf
çektirir böyle bir an
[Alkış]
Tabii YouTube ayrı bir mecra ve ben
artık böyle kısmen tanınan bir adam
haline geldim ve bir gün bir mesaj daha
aldım
Ömer Bey merhaba biz sizin gibi
eğitimlerinizi çok beğendik bizim için
eğitim hazırlar mısınız diyen kim
Turkcell Turkcell geleceğe yazanlar
Turkcell'in bir sosyal sorumluluk
projesi ücretsiz eğitimlerin
yayınlandığı bir portal ve benim eğitim
hazırlamamı istediler Tamam dedim buraya
da bir eğitim hazırladım ve tabii
Turkcell Türkiye'nin en büyük GSM
operatörü ismi çok kuvvetli buraya
eğitim hazırlamak ayrı bir havalı Niye
Çünkü bütün videolarınızın sonunda
Turkcell'in logosu var altında
o zaman hadi başlayalım
bütün videolarını
bitiriyor gerçekten çok havalı
pandeminin başıydı
bir telefon aldım
Ömer Bey biz sizi sosyal medyadan takip
ediyoruz eğitimlerinize baktık şu anda
bakanlığımız bir çalışma başlattı ve
pandemi döneminde çocuklar gençler evde
dururken kendilerini geliştirsin diye
Onlara ücretsiz eğitimlerin
yararlanacağı yapılacağı bir platform
oluşturmak istiyoruz
hazine Maliye Bakanlığı bünyesinde 1
milyon istihdam projesinin bir parçası
olarak oraya eğitim hazırlar mısınız
Tabii dedim ve BTT Akademi oraya eğitim
hazırladım Şu anda 5 tane eğitimim var
burada ve 200 binden fazla öğrenci oldu
totale baktığımız zaman tüm
platformlarda Yaklaşık 300 binden fazla
tekil kişinin eğitim aldığı bir
pozisyona geldi bu aslında bizim
çağımızın ne kadar fırsatlarla dolu
olduğunu bize sunan büyük bir durum
Tabii
bu paylaşmanın keyfine varınca buradaki
faaliyetlerin birçoğu ticari ama beni
Asıl mutlu eden şey bu ticari
faaliyetlerden Daha ziyade paylaşarak
insanlara yardımcı olmak ve bilgi
paylaşmak Bu anlamda 40 hayatın
üniversiteye gittim birçok topluluğun
gönüllü bir üyesiyim etkinlikler
eğitimler geliştiriyoruz
gerçekleştiriyoruz Tabii bu da
birilerinin dikkatini çekiyor
Microsoft'un bir programı var bir ödül
programı var Erkan Hocam da o programa
dahil MP most Professional en değerli
profesyonel Ee Microsoft'un sektöre ve
topluluklara gönüllü katkı sağlayan
antik profesyonellerine vermiş olduğu
bir ödül 2020 yılında ben bu ödülü aldım
her sene yenilenen bir ödül Şu anda da
bu ödül devam ediyor Bu benim için
oldukça kıymetli Zira Hani Microsoft'un
sayfasında böyle İsminizin
biyografinizin resminizin olması
gerçekten çok kıymetli ve şu an tüm
dünyada sanıyorum 3000 tane mvp var
Türkiye'de yaklaşık 22-23 tane mpu var
hani onlardan biri olmak gerçekten benim
için çok çok kıymetli filmi biraz başa
alalım mı ne vardı
yanlış bölümü Seçen umutsuz bir çocuk ve
bölüm değiştirmek isteyen bir öğrenci
arkadaşlar tarafından edilen bir davet
ve bu davete bir şekilde Bu bir fırsat
olabilir diye giren birisi o davetin
sonunda elde edilen bir başarı ve Daha
önemlisi kendini keşfetme süreci
sonrasında
iş bulma kolay bir iş bulma sonrasında
daha iyi bir iş bulma sonrasında gelen
bir teklifi ya bu angarya işine gerek
var diye reddetmeyip o çocuklara destek
olmak adına kendi şartlarını oluşturarak
bir eğitim şeyi oluşturma bir eğitim
sistemi geliştirme
akabinde YouTube kanalı irdemi geleceğe
yazanlar btka değil mi ve son olarak
Microsoft
Bu hikayeye baktığınız zaman 23 yıl
öncesine gittiğiniz zaman bu günü Ben
hayal edemezdim Ne hayal edebilirdim ne
planlayabilirdim olmak istediğim yerde
miyim kesinlikle Ama işte bütün bu
noktaya gelene kadar o hesaplamadan
yaptığımız Ama iyi niyetle yaptığımız
birçok şey hayatta bize bu güzellikleri
sundu dedik ya bağlantı hayatınızda
önemsiz gibi görünen her şey aslında
ileride olabilecek çok çok önemli
noktaların birer kilometre taşını da biz
bunu ancak şimdi görebiliyoruz
Evet 10 yıl sonra bir de bakmışsınız
sizin hikayenizin başladığı yer tam
olarak burası bu salon çok teşekkür
ederim Dinlediğiniz